okay
good morning everyone uh we'll open up
the
commerce committee's hearing uh hearings
and we have the first bill uh house bill
1146 relative to condo instruments and
condom special assessments and hear from
the prime sponsor
good morning
representatives good morning
chairman hunt
and and esteemed colleagues
well this bill i'm sure is very
unpopular but i i put it in not only
because i've
been president of our association at uh
in rochester
at least two terms
and i've been on uh our condo uh
association committee the board of
directors for decades i am no longer on
the condo association board of directors
uh however i do keep my finger on the
pulse
and we
[Music]
i understand
all of the complaints that i've gotten
in my email
but the purpose for this was that this
last time that we had an increase in our
condominium fees
it was quite a jump
and the
association members were angry
and so we talked about it
and they said well we just voted a
majority of us a pretty good majority of
us just voted
to
stop this fee from going in
why didn't that work and i said because
you need two-thirds and so out of 60
units which is the size of the
condominium association that i'm a
member of and i've owned two condos and
i've been there since 1995. so i don't
even want to count how many years that
is it makes me feel old
so
i said all right let's try for a simple
majority which would be 50
plus one
and at that point
the association members would have been
able to reject the decision of the board
of directors
and i know that that makes everyone very
nervous because now the association
owners and members actually have a say
instead of letting the board
have the say
and i understand representative boards
so it's it's there's a lot of tension
but i wanted to put this in because they
wanted to have a say i did not touch the
two-thirds for any other decisions to be
made we just carved out the the fees and
that was going to be it
and if this doesn't work we'll i'll just
work on the 40 members that will need to
override the board of directors next
time because we got really close
but
they were they were angry i was kind of
upset too because of the jump in the
fees it was huge
and uh so that's why that's why i've
i've submitted this uh piece of
legislation in hopes that it will pass
but i know that it won't thank you very
if you have any questions from
the committee members yes representative
thank you very much when you refer to as
condominium fees are you talking simply
about the monthly fees nothing else no
assessment assessment trash base
anything of that sort
thank you yes thank you for the question
uh yes that's that is correct so none of
the other decisions by the board would
be affected by this they still remain at
two-thirds
it really is oh and um
i did get a call from
a banker or bankers that were concerned
about the condominiums being able to the
associations being able to procure loans
in case that there's a need for it which
we've had several situations where we've
had to get loans for the association
and
when i took out
or added in i can't remember which one
it was
but
the um
special assessments weren't touched
either so that made them happy and
they're they're like fine we see no
problem with this so really if if you
have a roof problem or you need to do a
siding or something happens we actually
had a section of our our condos are not
stacked we have
sections of condos and so there was one
section that actually
burned
terribly and the whole that whole thing
had to be rebuilt they those members of
the association were were displaced and
had to live in a hotel for months
um
but they we did rebuild so at that point
we needed to to get a loan for some uh
important things and we were able i i
just know that being on the board being
president of the board and having
subcommittees that i had formed in the
whole nine yards that
we were doing just fine with maybe
incremental
condominium fee increases
before the two-thirds law went in
and
special assessments were you know nobody
likes a special assessment really i mean
you know how long do we have to put up
with this
but we the special assessments worked
just fine and then when they
peel off then then you're back down to
a reasonable level instead of having to
maybe you know
supplement
in in cases where there may be a tree
that goes through a roof or something
like that so sorry to have such a long
answer thank you for the question
representative burroughs
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question which is um i was
wondering if you've spoken to other
stakeholders who may um feel that this
is this is problematic beyond your own
condo association
i i have had
some conversations with them and i do
understand some of the problems that
arise as far as
the
lack of involvement
of
and i understand this i understand the
whole
i've been there
and and so the reason why i have
introduced this bill is because we we
were
wanting to turn it into a simple
majority but i know that it does raise
some problems but then you also have
you know i read one email where
from from actually a friend someone i
went to school with
in laconia
and he said well by having the
two-thirds put in place and into law
that prevents
the association members from being able
to override the board and i just thought
to myself good lord so by putting the
two-thirds in you completely take the
voice away from the members
and unless you really push it which i'm
able to do because i'm really pushy
but
but yeah i do i i understand both sides
but i i'm hoping for for a sorry
follow-up please further question may
inquire so i i believe i've text for
protect um if i'm wrong let me know
isn't there a statewide
association
that represent condos and if so have you
they don't like it
that's a short that's the short and
sweet answer to that one
yeah
um
so
needless to say uh you have no other
supporters for this bill i mean i got a
whole pile of
pile of people who are opposed to it so
um and this committee has
not only did it pass it and we've had
this issue try to repeal it and revisit
it several times so we're we all pretty
well
but i i i want to take this opportunity
just to make sure that some of my
thoughts and arguments are still true so
you are a board member
did you say
i was i am not currently a board member
on the association board of directors i
have been president
two terms and then you know other terms
i've just been on so so when this big
raise came you were not on the board at
the time no no okay
uh
i assume that the board made a big
presentation about why the increase was
well there wasn't much of an explanation
we didn't there those of us who
disagreed with it uh voiced our opinions
and we our board is is uh doesn't like
to
communicate very well
so there was not a whole lot of of back
and forth it was just a kind of a shut
up type of a deal ouch okay so um
and and we have heard this
before that boards are are maybe
aloof or elitist in some way but i was
intrigued by the idea that you were
actually on the board for a while said
so which of course this was never a
problem when you were on the board right
you know yeah so so the question then is
no
probably
because we would think that one of the
resolutions of this problem would be
that maybe the board needs to be
replaced with people who are more
communicative to the condo owners would
you believe
thank you very much
okay like i said um everybody's in
opposition this committee has pretty
much been on record for years to is in
support of the current law so please uh
don't belabor too much but i know that
you all came up here and want to make
sure we
we get it
so uh we'll start out with gary
darium
good morning make sure you push the
button
there you go perfect okay
sorry about that my name is gary
d'addario i'm an attorney that practices
community association law i'm a partner
at the firm of marcus rico emerald
brooks
but i'm here in my capacity as the
chairperson of new hampshire's
legislative action committee through the
community associations institute
i'll try to be brief especially given
what you just said
but i do just
want to convey some information to the
committee regarding this bill
so associations uh in this state are
non-profits and so the only financial
resources they have are the assessments
they collect from their unit owners they
have of course important business to
take care of with that money insurance
electricity landscaping snow removal
things of this nature and all that they
have to work with
is the budget that they establish and
then the assessments they collect from
the community and i mentioned that only
to make clear that to the extent that
the board ends up with their hands tied
about the amount of money that they can
collect
there isn't an alternative resource it's
not like they're going to dip into
profits or something like that
because it doesn't exist for them
a few years ago
in 2016
when there was a large amendment passed
to 356b the condominium act in the state
one of the things that was included was
an explicit fiduciary obligation that
the board has to the associations
and so
i think it becomes that much more
important when a board is saddled with a
fiduciary obligation to do what's best
for the property i think it becomes that
much more important to allow them to do
their job
for them to to be hamstringed with
something as important as the financial
resources that are going to be collected
over the course of a year and used for
the property i think can put them in a
very difficult position depending on
what the needs of the property are
and of course by way of reminder boards
are elected by the community which means
that in a community where
the majority of people don't like what
the board is doing they have the ability
at the next election to replace all or
some of their board
that's what happens when the elections
occur
that maintenance
the taking care of the property that the
board does with the funds that they
collect it goes well beyond aesthetics
i think unfortunately
some folks erroneously believe that it's
really just a matter of to what extent a
community has curb appeal
but it really it goes much deeper than
that especially when a property starts
to lose curb appeal and then problems
sort of further develop
we have all at this point heard of the
tragedy that occurred in florida
the loss of human life in a building
i will tell you that community
associations institute operates on a
national level
and in response to that incident they
established three national committees to
study what went wrong and how that might
be avoided in the future
i was asked to serve on two of those
national committees and i did so
and i will share with you that what came
out of those committees were essentially
two primary recommendations
one that buildings get inspected more
frequently by persons qualified to
perform those inspections throughout the
life of the building especially as it
ages
in two and this relates to the ability
of associations to conduct that first
aspect the second big recommendation was
that communities have to do a better job
of raising funds so that they have the
money that they need to address problems
when they're discovered uh it turns out
that down there there's a lot of arguing
that there it was known that work needed
to be done and there was a lot of
arguing about it based on the cost and
unfortunately you know that's typical
it's basic human nature for people to
not want to have to pay more money
and i can tell you since working with
boards is is all that i do
boards don't love raising condo fees
they are owners as well and they pay
those same fees so they're getting hit
with whatever increase they apply to the
community as well
in addition the board members feel the
ire of the community so they don't take
it lightly and they don't want to do it
but there are times when they need to do
it
and
looking ahead unfortunately in the
immediate future
based on the increasing costs of
everything based on inflation that's
applying to everything in the years
ahead boards are going to have to
increase their budgets possibly
substantially just to maintain the same
level of services that they're getting
now so the idea that there would be an
inability on their part
to raise the fees without having a
majority of the community appear to say
yes we want to pay more
is is not workable and it's putting
those board members in what i think is
going to be a really untenable
situation and it's doing so
or would do so if this bill passed for
no good reason because as the sponsor
just explained to you mechanisms already
exist
the communities in new hampshire based
on the existing law have the ability to
override the board's budget yes it's by
a two-thirds majority but that's the
same standard that applies in most sets
of condominium documents for other
community decisions including amendments
to their documents so it's not
inappropriate to have that standard in
fact
i was here when it was being considered
and i said it then and i'll say it again
now it's entirely appropriate that it
takes a majority of the community to
reject the board's budget because it's
the board that has the obligation to
create the budget in the first place and
has a fiduciary obligation to make that
budget suitable for what they know the
needs of the property to be
but again if a board came up with an
absolutely
absurd budget the community does have a
means to act already
that's in place so
i also just want to mention briefly
because bankers were mentioned to you in
the the
issue of associations getting bank loans
it is somewhat of a popular
thing right now because a lot of
associations have not set aside the
money that they should have over the
past you know 20 30 years for what are
now major projects coming due the
lending industry has responded they do
offer products now loans that are
specifically geared towards condominiums
in new hampshire they have already
adapted
since 2016
when they found out that the community
could even by the two-thirds reject the
board's budget they changed the closing
documents to protect themselves and the
bankers have told me that directly there
are now additional papers required that
the board needs to sign additional votes
that need to happen and be documented
specifically because the banks are now
being asked to lend money to
associations whose communities
next year could show up at the annual
meeting and reject the board's budget
so even under existing law
the bankers have already had to take
account
the risk associated and they've already
done that
so i would submit to you that that's not
really an issue here so
in closing i would just like to say that
the new hampshire legislative action
committee of the community association's
institute opposes the bill
we oppose it for the reasons that i've
stated and
we hope that you will
leave the law as it currently stands it
is sufficient in this area and again in
the immediate future it's really what is
needed more so than than what's being
proposed
thank you do you accept questions
do um
condominiums
get advised in terms of amortization of
debt in other words
do they put aside money
for
areas that might need uh work are
predictable
so a lot try to do that
i can't say that it's universally done
but there are engineers that are capable
of providing specific reports some of
these engineers much like certain
attorneys or accountants or other types
of businesses actually specialize in
working with condominiums and boards can
get a study that tracks you know what
their needs will be in the future
the engineers that do a good job with
this even project
you know the rising costs over time and
things like that so that um associations
you know would be able to put the money
aside unfortunately you know all of the
associations that are 20 30 years old
right now
haven't necessarily done that to the
extent they should and that's why the
bank loans are becoming popular
for those who have to face major
projects
representative bartlett
thank you mr chair
thanks for coming before commerce again
mr d'addario
welcome
have you had a chance to run this bill
back past any of um your the condo
associations you represent
uh yes
and what could i just ask you for the
question thank you um if you've had a
a sense of what some of them feel
uh certainly if i were to summarize
overwhelmingly
my clients feel that if changes like
this are made to the law
that uh being on the board will be no
place to be in the future
because if you pass a budget that
accounts for the financial needs of the
association but it involves an increase
in the fee and then the community shows
up to say we're not paying it
then as a board member you don't want to
be there saddled with the responsibility
of the consequences of what happens if
the property isn't properly cared for
and so most board members
that i'm hearing from would leave the
post and many of them have no idea who
would step up under those circumstances
well fat
great thank you very much thank you uh
be sure to push the red button
thank you for taking the time to hear my
testimony this morning my name is lou
gargiulo i reside in hampton falls i'm
the ceo and founder of great north
property management in exeter new
hampshire
my firm is responsible for the
management of more than 25 000
condominium and homeowner association
units that house approximately 75 000
people i'm here today to voice my strong
opposition
to hb 1146
as it currently stands it is hard enough
to get unit owners to run for the board
positions many condos that i represent
have unfilled board positions and have
to beg people to stand as a board member
owner apathy
is a struggle and participation
sometimes is difficult
this bill will create an untenable
situation from that perspective
it will make the ability to pass a
budget much more complicated but beyond
that it will have other implications
and
they came to me as i sat here this
morning
as a an owner of a large management
company we are requested to provide
information to lending institutions
regarding reserve levels uh regarding a
whole array of different questions so a
person can get a loan
the standards have increased since the
tragedy at surfside in florida
exponentially
banks and mortgage companies are very
hesitant to lend money to condominium
associations if a bill like this comes
to fruition
not only will it create problems
internally it will make it virtually
impossible for condominium owners to
sell their units because institutions
will look at it and say the funding
levels are not sufficient as attorney
daddario said
there is an outcry when there is an
increase in fees but people have come to
understand it and frankly they're going
to have to understand it a lot more as
time passes the whole landscape of the
condominium association from an
operational perspective is changing and
all of it is now being pointed to
surfside in florida
the
situation there
has caused people to re-look at the
construction stability and operation of
community associations and with that the
only way they prosper is if there is
sufficient funding to maintain them this
bill will have a chilling effect on
having that funding available
with that said i ask you the current law
is more than sufficient it gives the
individuals involved in the association
a voice i think it was was well crafted
and i see at this point no reason to
change it i ask you to find this bill in
expedient the legislate
any questions
uh i see none good thank you thank you
good morning good morning
my name is tom tessier and i live in
national new hampshire at the hayden
green condominiums
i've served on two prior boards of condo
associations one in hebron new hampshire
and one in bridgewater and now the one
in nashua
and i echoed the sentiments of the two
past speakers in their opposition
and our association board is in strong
opposition of this bill for the same
reasons that we just talked about and
i won't reiterate all of those items
but i can tell you
we are volunteers
there are five of us and if we had to
hire a management company
to do the work for our association it
would be thousands of dollars in extra
expense
and
from what i've heard our own association
we've been doing a great job we have a
good reserve
we've only had to raise our fees once
from believe it or not 115 to 125
dollars
and i do recall that when we did that 10
dollar increase we did have some people
who were
strongly opposed to it but we had to do
it to keep up with the expenses of our
association
if
our volunteer board
is restricted
is proposing
that i can tell you right now that the
five of us would probably resign because
we wouldn't want to take on the
liabilities that would be facing us
and i don't know what would happen i
don't know if anybody would step up to
serve on the board because we haven't
been able in seven years to get anyone
to step up uh and it comes up every year
as
the board seats rotate nobody's come up
so i don't think we'd be able to get
anybody to do that
we have 80 and 90 year old residents in
our community who don't come to meetings
don't want to come to meetings
sometimes they vote sometimes they don't
so it would be very very difficult
for us uh to maintain what we've done in
the past
and we've done a good job so we are in
total opposition
of this bill
thank you for your time
fair enough thank you very much
sir velo
good morning uh my name is vincent
cervelo i'm
from 335 fox run road in hudson so i
speak for myself as well as being the
president of the village of barrett hill
association
and i very much like the other gentleman
before me and in opposition to uh
this bill it serves no purpose because
the board per se has a an a difficult
job in itself just to conduct business
in a normal normal cycle to add anything
more to that you know we our board
members are parsimonious and judicious
in how we
we handle
fees and we don't have any assessments
because in our monthly programs or
monthly fees we adjust for both the
operating budget and the reserves to
replace
and unfortunately this year we've been
faced with
we're replacing decks at this
association that's 30 years old and
we've got wood prices that have gone up
35 to 40 percent to cope difficult to
cope with
snow plowing the landscaping have gone
up from 15 to 30 percent
unseen
escalations in prices
you know we have five board members and
we
continually approach the community about
providing you know more board members
and volunteering and everything else and
unfortunately the hard reality is that
only a minuscule amount ever comes
forward to provide those
the board is a representative governance
of the the association and we try to do
it always in the best interest of all
the residents uh on an ongoing basis so
this this bill should just be allowed to
die quietly because it serves no purpose
so i thank you for listening to me
okay
thank you
you got one more card left uh edward
colbert
hi good morning
um
i live at partridgeberry hills it's a
condominium association um in nashua new
hampshire
it's 304 units it's a large property
i also serve as vice president of the
board there
and
we regularly have difficulty meeting
the 33 and a third uh quorum to just get
the business of the annual meeting done
and um sometimes we have to take two or
three passes at that that's the level of
apathy and that's really what we're all
struggling with here is the apathy uh um
so uh i believe owners do have a voice
and um
if
if uh the impacts of
this bill would be
very damaging to boards trying to get
business done if there's an emergency
repair they have to go out and it's very
very hard to get
um
get participation from owners um in in
our association about 70 percent of the
um condos are rented so owners may not
even be in this country very often it's
just difficult to get uh people on board
and um
i uh i
just strongly urge you all to consider
the
it's already difficult for volunteers
um
to provide good fiscal governance i'm
very lucky i've served on a board that's
never had a special assessment in 40
years but the property is 40 years old
and it does need constant repair and
getting those things done is very
difficult and it would not serve any
member of the association have a board's
hands tied here so i do urge you to
oppose this bill accordingly thank you
very much
thank you uh having no more cards left
the overnight
list we have
no support and six suppose
and
the sign in sheet
uh everybody is opposed
including who didn't testify tom arnold
helen hooker
uh
everybody else spoke so with that we
you
okay we'll open up the public hearing in
house bill 1380 and hear from the prime
sponsor
representative matt houghton good
morning representative van halen and
mike yeah you got to push the red button
push the reverse i apologize yeah no
problem so for the record i am connie
van houten new hampshire state
representative from hillsborough
district 45
45 spans the three wards on the west
side of manchester
the northernmost ward where i live
borders on hooksett and many condominium
and homeowners associations
have been developed there for the clerk
i do have a written testimony that i
will get to you afterward
although i will deviate from it perhaps
i'd like to begin
differently than i had planned
um
i think perhaps we need to do some
definitions
uh the people behind me who have spoken
on behalf of condominiums and
condominium associations
are different than the people that would
be referenced with this bill
condominiums and condominium
associations
are different from homeowners
associations in a couple of basic ways
perhaps the most basic way is that the
condominium owner owns an individual
unit i am a condominium owner i own a
unit i don't own a building a
freestanding building i don't own any
lawn i don't know any of those types of
things
i am a member of the communities
association though and i share an
ownership stake
in what the association owns
now the homeowners association which is
the subject of the bill before us today
is different each owner owns an
individual property perhaps an
individual lot as well so for the most
part when we talk about homeowners
association we are talking about
freestanding units
in both types of associations both types
of communities there are shared and
common interests and and those will be
impactful as we talk about the bill here
so to return to my comments i'm here
today to introduce
house bill 1380 on behalf of
constituents whoever they said are my
neighbors and other new hampshire
citizens
many of them contacted me after a 2020
house bill passed by this committee was
passed by the house on a voice vote and
then of course
covid reared its head and the senate
laid the bill on the table
the bill before you today is identical
to that bill
hb 1380 prohibits homeowners association
deeds or other instruments pertaining to
conveyance of real property or interest
therein
from prohibiting or restricting the
installation and use of solar
photovoltaic energy systems
the bill makes any portion of a deed or
other legal instrument that prohibits or
places unreasonable limits
on the installation or use of solar void
and unenforceable
in essence
installation or use of solar systems
would no longer be subject to terms of
the governing documents
of the homeowners associations under
this bill
this bill does not require that such
documents be rewritten however and it is
not a mandate
instead hb 1380 puts the decision about
solar into the hands of the owner of the
unit
rather than by permission of others such
as the board of directors
currently though it would be possible
for an association on an individual
basis
to grant some requests for solar
installation and use and not others
thereby even changing the physical
unifor uniformity of the association
that many people cherish as well
i do realize that there are objections
to this a bill of this sort uh part of
that has to do with the fact that condo
and homeowner's law is relatively young
in the scheme of things
i do understand and am respectful of
those differences and those concerns
however in bringing this bill forward on
behalf of constituents and other new
hampshire residents i am honoring their
concerns about increasing costs of
energy and the ramifications of those
increasing costs
and the need for clean and renewable
energy and expansion of its use
some association documents have existed
for decades
and more new hampshire citizens and
residents have gravitated to ownership
and living in communities of homeowners
associations since those documents were
written
but the landscape of our current world
colored by topics like inflation supply
chain issues and climate concerns
mentioned in everyday news has changed
this legislation is not without
precedent for example the california
solar rights act
prevents homeowners associations
excuse me these masks are difficult to
breathe through sometimes
the california solar
solar rights act prevents hoas or
homeowners associations from limiting a
person's ability to install solar panels
as do more than two dozen other states
if this were to pass
solar installation would still be
subject to local ordnance ordinances
zoning regulation permitting and
inspection
and would not intrude upon common or
limited common elements of the
association again that's because in the
homeowners association the owner owns
the building as well as probably the lot
the bill however would allow an owner or
owners of a unit under their control to
make choices about their energy systems
and cost of energy
i'd like to close by just highlighting
three of the misconceptions that exist
partially because of the interchangeable
use of the words condo and homeowners
association
first of all homeowners and are not
homeowner associations are not condos
the property is controlled by the owner
and there are
and therefore this bill would talk about
installation on that property not on
common areas
so if i owned a homeowner if i were in a
homeowners association and owned my own
building and controlled my roof took
care of the repairs for my roof and
other another ways had control of my
roof i could put my solar panels there
that would not be considered common
property
also this is not a mandate
it is actually almost the reverse of a
mandate it's lifting a requirement that
exists in some homeowners association
documents the requirement being that
solo panthers panels cannot be used and
therefore there would be a freeing of
the ability of the homeowner who owns
the building
to use solar panels if he wished he or
she wished sorry
and finally
the documents
documents as you've heard from people
behind me talking about condominiums are
critical to the running and operation
of any kind of a community
organization like this
those documents would not become void
and unenforceable
the only thing that this bill as it's
written and as the other 24 plus bills
are written would do
is to make sections or portions that
talk about solar panels
void and unenforceable the documents
would not need to be written the
documents would stand however there
would be aspects that were unenforceable
that is also what we see in other
legislation throughout the country
so thank you very much for allowing me
to present this it is a
passion of many of my constituents to
have solar for many reasons
related to economy related to clean air
related to
the ability to exist in home in which
they will be happy and comfortable for
many years i'll take questions thank you
questions uh representative abel
yes welcome back we're so happy to see
you good to see you thank you
um
uh would you believe that i live in a
homeowners association in which
there are
which are all
evolve
individual structures
and
in which there are
some
houses that have solar panels and some
do not and this has existed for a long
time
and i just
want uh but
would you that's my first question i
have a second question uh absolutely
although we talk about uniformity when
we talk about homeowners associations um
by virtue even of topography things are
different um some people are not
oriented to to be able to harness solar
for instance and would not be interested
in it interested in it some people live
on hills and the driveways are
configured differently so um although
there is a great deal of uniformity
there
doesn't exist total uniformity and
apparently your homeowners association
is elected to allow solar to be part of
that change from uniformity
further question yes thank you um
my question involves whether the solar
panels would be on the roof of a
building or could be
on the
i think there are probably four or five
different placements that that have
worked in
homeowners associations that have used
uh this bill to get solar energy for
them
um
the bill specifies that common areas
cannot be used for placement and so the
condo ducts the not the docks i'm sorry
the association docks the documents that
go with the homeowners associate
association will play a role here
if for instance you have a unit it's an
individual free standing unit and the
roof is controlled totally but totally
by you you could put your panels there
if the lot is also controlled totally
totally by you you could put your panels
there
if however according to the documents
for the association
they are association maintained or no
association managed and you do not pay
for instance for
roof repairs then you could not put them
there
the common areas
element gets a little bit murky because
there are things like limited common
areas and true common areas but as
crafted this bill
only allows you to put
you as a homeowners association member
allows you to put these panels in places
that you are in control of
and the roof or the lawn if that were
the case by documents could be those
places
okay
yes representative greeson
thank you mr thank you representative
for taking our questions
what is the definition of significantly
as it pertains to significantly
increasing the cost or expense or
significantly decreasing the efficiency
and who determines whether it's
significant well that would again be a
board thing a lot of these a lot of
these elements with homeowners
associations as i said are run by
documents and boards and so the board of
directors would probably assume that um
let's say that they um wanted to be sure
that you
you maybe they would ask you to only put
your panels in a certain area of the
property and perhaps that area of the
property does not get enough solar
interaction
to harness this energy that would
probably significantly reduce that
however as as i think with most things
particularly with with condo and
homeowners association law being as
young as it is i think some of these
things are evolving as we go and some of
them as as we've heard from people
behind me with whom i agree on a lot of
issues but some of them are up to the
board of directors or volunteer group
who do their very best to to manage the
associations that they that they deal
with and to come up with the right
answers and some of the things we've
talked about previously
involve mechanisms to make sure that
those best interests are are are
maintained so to answer your question
i'm not sure a hundred percent
but it would be within the homeowners
association themselves to to work those
types of things out but seriously if
someone told me that i could put my
solar panels only inside my garage
um i would have a concern
yeah i guess that's where my question
would aim at
and that is
given that we we don't single family
homes and i know homeowners associations
can
for whatever reason they want to call it
that but
for the for the discussion purpose we're
talking about people who own
their own house in a stand-alone
separate building
do you actually have a story or an
analogy story where
somebody wanted to put photovoltaics on
their building and went to their
homeowners association and they the
homeowner association said no yes um and
that was the genesis of my reintroducing
this bill which was also in the last
session um
the woman is has currently moved but
it's like a psychiatrist
i i do live in a condu association but
just above me is a homeowners
association
and she had a marvelous marvelous home
um very nice and and very well appointed
and she was she did request solar from
her condo association they did put it to
a vote that was their means of of
dealing with the issue and she came she
came armed with a lot of information
she just sold that that caught the her
freestanding condo for half a million
dollars
but she was also told that that could
easily have been a hundred thousand
dollars more
she also gave me some figures that
showed that she could have recouped the
cost of of her equipment her
installation equipment
in seven or eight years this is 03102 so
it's uh near hooksett
uh and that
at the end of that seven year period she
would have paid off the insulation costs
begun savings and then being able to
hopefully uh return some of that energy
under a net metering relationship but
she was denied
since then the neighbors decided they
didn't want her to do that right and
what they were citing was the aesthetic
element
i i understand that i understand that
people buy condominiums and and
homeowners association buildings because
they do agree with the aesthetic as i've
said again i don't want to mix things up
here but i do live in a condominium
i have previously owned another
condominium i've served on boards of
directors
um
we're talking about homeowners
associations no i'm just i'm coming to a
point
there when i bought my condo there were
many many things that i could check off
my list for there were a few things that
i totally didn't like
and so
i had to accept that that uniformity was
not going to totally happen i have some
incredible pillars
that
i understand they are thematically
appropriate but they've always bothered
me it didn't stop me from buying from
buying the um the condo association so
uniformity
and by the way other units don't have
those pillars
i sometimes wonder why me why do i end
up with these pillars
but the uniformity aspect it's important
the aesthetic element is important but
we're talking here about energy savings
we're talking here about clean energy
we're talking about the futures
of the condominium uh and as homeowners
associations i heard a report driving in
this morning that gas prices are likely
to hit four dollars a gallon in the very
near future
uh energy costs energy uses um are
important to us especially in the world
that has changed so drastically in the
okay
okay so uh
similar to last bill we have
nobody else in support so we'll just go
through
the
opposition and we'll start out with the
community association let's do with gary
d'adrio once you start out gary and
good morning again and thank you again
for
allowing me some time for the record my
name is gary d'addario i'm here in my
capacity as the chair of the new
hampshire legislative action committee
of the community associations institute
and i practice community association law
here in new hampshire
that's the sole focus of my practice
so
i'll begin with
some of the actual language of the bill
it starts out by saying that any
covenant
condition
or restriction
contained in any deed contract mortgage
security instrument or other instrument
to the extent that they unreasonably uh
restrict one's ability to install solar
shall be void and unenforceable
so um
that's really pretty bright actually i
want to
so
excuse me empowerment i just want to
take a quick step back
we are not to be clear
both as a group and myself personally
we're not against the idea of solar or
against the idea of
clean energy we're just not i myself had
solar installed at the last house that i
lived in
but i was not within an association and
there weren't any uh documents or
restrictions that i was supposed to
so i wanted to make that much clearer
getting back to the language of the bill
um
what i just read was very broad
these documents deeds and contracts
mortgages security instruments
they already exist
and there are a lot of folks out there
who i think we should consider
and who presumably wanted to get the
benefit of their bargain
i understand that homeowners
associations are different than
condominiums but i represent homeowners
associations as well
and what they have in common is that
like condominiums they exist in part
because of their documents
their documents create these
neighborhoods they lay out the terms and
conditions uh by which they're supposed
to operate and the restrictions that
presumably all of those who voluntarily
agree to buy into that association are
willing to live by
and so um i think they really need to be
allowed to to go ahead and do that to to
live within the confines of the
governing documents that created them
and that everyone who's become a member
in the meantime had an opportunity to
review and presumably agree to live by
those owners who bought on the basis of
restrictions and these people exist i've
spoken to them
for some they really have a primary
interest and a primary focus on living
in a community that has a very set
appearance
including all the consistency and
everything looking the same the way they
do in condominiums and associations and
i don't see why we should deprive those
folks of the benefit of the bargain if
they found an association whose
documents had restrictions that they
wanted some folks have bought into the
association because they wanted to live
around people with those restrictions
and that having been said it's also
important to note that those
restrictions can change internally
the state doesn't need to override and
overrule all of these documents and say
that they're unenforceable and and say
what associations can and can't do
because they have that power already
through the amendment process
so in any association that for whatever
reason has documents
that would be overly restrictive of of
solar right now
to the extent that a majority of that
community decided that they wanted solar
they would simply vote to amend the
documents and make the necessary changes
and adopt solar and i think that we
should let communities do it that way
because again otherwise what we would
really have is the state
imposing changes and invalidating
documents that already exist
that that people feel that they should
be living by and that courts would
enforce as covenants running with the
land
um
uh my last comments would be this uh
based on what the the bill sponsor said
um to the extent that this is intended
to apply for
or to homeowners associations and not to
condominiums
i think that easily enough
a provision could be inserted that
explicitly states that it doesn't apply
to condominiums i think without that
they would certainly be those folks who
would argue that perhaps it does
especially since it's being inserted
into 477 which is more of a general real
estate
section of the rsas
my next comment about if the bill was
was to move forward
by way of recommendation um again we
heard from the bill sponsor that
the bill is not meant to allow owners to
put
solar equipment in places that they
don't control
in other words the common areas of an
association which you know no owner has
a right
to exercise dominion over
to that end i know that that's the word
that's used in the statute areas
controlled by such an owner
but in my experience whether we're
talking about
condominiums or associations the
documents generally don't speak in terms
of control
it's more about ownership
you know owners own their unit or in the
case of a homeowner association they may
own the home itself the whole
freestanding
but they typically don't own other areas
uh in any event my suggestion is to
replace the term controlled um because
it could cause uh potential confusion
um with um areas that are solely owned
by the unit owner in question and i
think that that would at least if this
bill were to go forward i think that
that would at least uh prevent some
confusion in some arguments that might
otherwise occur over where things might
be placed
thank you for your time
representative herbert has a question
so am i correct in
what you said
am i correct in assuming that say
technology changes or whatever occurs in
the future
gas goes net gas goes to a hundred
the existing law allows for
a democratic vote of the association
and and that can change
the uh so so the state legislature is
not
needed a new law
outside of what your recommendation is
it's you already have the ability we
already have the ability as a homeowners
association to
update and if we so wish
correct that's actually i would suggest
an excellent way to describe the
situation that this bill isn't needed
because if a community wanted
to allow for solar they could do that
through the document amendment process
that already exists that would be based
on a vote of that community
and by the way the reason why that's a
lot more fair
is that when people accept deeds
to properties that are in condominiums
or associations one of the provisions
states not only that they're taking
ownership of the property subject to
those documents but standard language
also says that they're taking the
property subject to any amendments to
those documents
and so that if that community should
vote to so amend their documents
technically speaking those owners all of
them even the ones that didn't want to
see you know a solar panel perhaps
all of them have agreed to live by those
documents if they're amended as well
but again the amendment that's
contemplated is by the community
you know not by the force of the state
great thank you very much thank you
good morning again good morning mr
chairman
yeah mike yeah sorry
i'm the ceo and founder of great north
property management
who manages approximately 25 000
condominium and homeowners association
units
i'm here today although i support clean
energy options and i believe in them i'm
here today to voice my strong objection
to house bill 1380. i'm doing so for the
following reasons and much of which
is reiterating with attorney
daddario said
many people buy into hoas homeowner
associations because they enjoy clean
and cohesive atmosphere in a
neighborhood governed by
established association documentations
and rules and regulations
that they understood when they acquired
the property
in this particular bill essentially
those restrictions
those
deeds are all going to be upended
in an effort to allow something that the
members did not bargain for when they
acquired the property
as attorney daddario said the resolution
in an association is very simple you
amend the documents to allow it and if
association wants it and if the majority
of unit owners want it
then you amend it
you cannot allow the minority of one
person or two people to control the
majority it's not fair it's not
appropriate so with that said i'm not
going to prolong your agony
i ask you to find this an expedient to
legislate i think it's bad public policy
to try to insert yourself into something
that already exists in statute and in
law so have a great day great thank you
very much
chair we'll call on uh
we get the right bill here make sure all
right vincent uh cervelo
again
morning again good morning again since
the the issues and the salient points
have already been
outlined there's no need for me to say
anything further and
i also favor clean energy and efficient
energy where we can secure it um
but
you know the the fact that heating oil
and gasoline have gone up from gasoline
in particular from 150
to now 350 is purely and simply the
function of bad policy in washington
and it's an incumbent i think on people
to really push back on on those types of
adjudications that cause that kind of
escalation because otherwise we have
plenty of fossil fuel in this country
thank you so much okay thank you
good morning again good morning again
speaking for myself and my wife and
board of directors of my association
i'm speaking in total opposition of this
bill
i don't see why the state should mandate
something that we can all already do and
that's already been approved i don't
understand that and with all due respect
new hampshire is not california i would
we own our own building and we could put
solar panels on our roof
my wife personally thinks they are
hideous and ugly
but someday and i've read something
about
some company was trying to develop roof
shingles that would actually act as
solar panels
if that happened maybe our association
would change and amend our documents and
allow it
another example
that would be comparable to what my wife
says about solar panels is we did have
one unit member put up pink flamingos on
her lawn
we didn't have any doc documents or
amendments that said that she couldn't
do that
but
when her neighbors saw it they were down
in less than a week
and we've since made provisions for that
not to happen again
um we we control our association we have
votes it's the democratic process
it's working great
i would think
99.999 of the time
so i really don't understand why
this should be mandated and
we are in total opposition and i thank
you for your time
okay thank you
we have a lot of pink flamingos in our
area because we're very close to
lunenburg leominster where they're all
made made in america so everybody seems
uh helen hecker
hooker
hello
uh my name is helen hoker i wrote a
little bit closer to mike i wrote a uh
an email uh pretty well stating my
opinion i am president of the condo
association at white rock and bow and
one thing that has
continually gone through my mind is i am
quite surprised that these two bills
even were introduced into uh and got as
far as they have gotten on what is
basically internal matters within
individual condo associations to which
people buy into
voluntarily
are not
asked to stay if they choose not to
like what's going on they have voices
they can oppose anything
but they are asked to live within what
they bought into which i have them sign
off on when they come they are presented
with the rules and regulations and the
condo docs they are asked to sign a
paper saying that they have read
and accept those rules and regulations
and it is by far not necessary for a
state to come in
and and even
suggest that these rules and regulations
to which they have agreed to can be
overridden
that's what i have to say
thank you fair enough
thank you very much
all right having no more cards
uh the overnight we have uh six
supporters and eight in opposition
and
in the committee room uh pretty much
everybody spoke so i won't bother
reading their names and with that we'll
okay
i'm waiting for my clerk to be prepared
and ready
okay don't worry we're gonna you'll be
out of here by lunchtime don't worry
okay
i would hope not you want to make sure
your bill gets a thorough hearing don't
you
okay
at least he's honest okay
i will open up the public hearing on
1378 and he's got his microphone on so
good morning representativery thank you
for the record my name is jordan ullery
representative hillsborough 37 and i'm
introducing house bill 1378
relative to the inspection of public
lodging houses
this is a very simple
uh bill it places no burden
not already placed on the business
to
maintain records
all it does is say that these records
need to be available
on the presentation of a warrant
our local chief of police and several of
the other surrounding towns that have a
lot larger number of motels routinely
get a warrant
for this type of uh information
it's a matter of privacy if you remember
back a few
years ago
we passed out of the uh general court an
amendment to the uh constitution that
was put on the ballot
it's one of the few
constitutional amendments that was
actually passed by an overwhelming
number of individuals and or persons
are when it was put on the ballot that
is a right to privacy we each have
in new hampshire enshrined in our
constitution a right to privacy
now the extent of that privacy can be
limited in certain cases we don't have a
right to privately kill someone
but we have the right
to general privacy
in our daily activities
and if we want to uh
what's that
actually something well there's our the
website that
that's out there that allows you to to
fine
you know that's
a
choice that you made and the other
person hopefully was doing it
consensually
so
that's that's perfectly fine
uh it's not fine but it's
none of the sheriff's interest as to
uh who's in that particular room and
what their names are
on a general
search
just a broad blanket search of what's
going on
which is what current law allows the
sheriff or police officer or i would
assume even though they're not mentioned
because the state police didn't
exist in uh what was it
um
when the bill was first or when this law
was first put into effect
so
it um
it's a really simple bill all we're
doing is saying yeah have to have a
present or a warrant
to which probable cause has been
attested which warrants have that's part
of a warrant at any rate
this is a constituent driven
bill
the
constituent is here he has testimony
that he would like to give as mr khan
and
regarding his family's own experience
which is
are
disturbing
but
the rule of law is to control government
this helps control government
now i will admit that the entire chapter
needs to be updated in some fashion yeah
um
and i'm open to some amendments
but the law itself needs to be present
for a wide variety of reasons
not the least of which is
i
had presented a bill to transportation
many years ago to allow for the safety
inspection of trucks which has already
uncovered some into
men coming down for labor uh illegal
labor and women who are coming down here
for the sex trade
that was several years ago that's just a
safety inspection that was a lot of
new hampshire registered vehicles but
now can be applied across the board as a
safety inspection so anyone who goes
through the toll
or the weigh stations can
may be subject to that
human trafficking is despicable
uh and there needs to be some method of
controlling that
but i think
merely asking for a warrant doesn't get
into that uh
the fact is that if i go to a motel i'm
expecting
some privacy of being in that hotel
while i'm there and not having the local
jean armory come in and
just and i know they don't and i know
this is going to sound
bad but they can right now just go
through the card and see who's there
and for what you know that's just all
just to see who's there
and
the 1970s
isn't appropriate
today
that's the essence of the bill i'd be
happy to work with the committee of
further additions or modifications of
this
particular chapter need to be taken are
there any questions mr chairman
evidently we do representative burroughs
is first
yes thank you for question taking my
question and this is a would you believe
and what do you think scenario this is a
real story in my community we had a
murder
an army navy store um
there were swat teams all over the place
so in that scenario when their time is
of the essence and they were i mean the
whole town was in lockdown we were
terrified of of what had happened
how would this bill impacted if if let's
say they thought that this person was
staying in a certain lodging um facility
um how would that impact the timing of
them going in to check that
under current law and i'm sure the the
the sheriff or the attorney general will
correct me but under current law
if you cannot search a house
without a warrant unless
and it's the unless
that is the important thing exigent
circumstances can be abused but they're
not
to a large part and if they are
then they're going to get
uh
the the entire case
is thrown out
uh fruit of the poisonous tree i think
is the uh the terminology that's used
so
it doesn't have an effect in my view on
that because exigent circumstances
would allow access to information
based upon the life of a person or
impending uh harm to a person in the
same fashion that uh
you know
a non-law enforcement person can use a
firearm to defend themselves or others
follow-up should that be in the bill
though
to specify that i don't think so
um i will leave that to the attorneys to
to to give some uh extra
oomph to it but i don't think so it's
not in the it's not in the uh the law
for search warrants
but if you hear somebody screaming
inside the building you can break into
that house
okay any other question so i guess i i
have a real problem with a statute um
but we'll start out with do you know any
hotel today
that has a book or a card system
well it depends on what you mean by book
well that's what the statute says yeah
well when was the statute written sir
evidently you just told us 1923.
and uh when was it last modified i have
no idea
i'll leave that to the attorney
general's office but i think it was 70
73 something like that
but actually if you take a look at the
uh
signing when you go to a motel you're
signing into a card system you're using
your card to get into the place
i suppose that would be a justification
you're correct sir some modification
needs to be made right well yeah but
even and i said oh well i had put my
credit card to look for
incidentals
it might not be my car it could be
somebody else's card it could be my
parents paid for me ahead of time
so that that's not telling you anything
other than you have another name that's
not that would be illegal you can't they
would the hotel would be in violation if
they were using that as the name
i think most hotels are in violation
today
perfect
representative johnson
you for taking my question
um
would this apply because
i'm i'm
the way i'm reading it that their book
or their
card system is now pretty much
electronic because i know when you go
into a hotel you need a
picture id but you cannot rent a room
yeah if
i you know the conferences that i go to
in different states and and uh even here
in the state with the knights of
columbus
when you go in well when you make your
reservation you give them the card
information that's going to secure the
room and then when you show up does that
information match the card information
is the routine procedure
now do we need to put that into law
modify this particular chapter in
some
manner so that it reflects current
business practices and business
practices into the future so the
language would be open-ended that
verification of identity upon
blah would be inappropriate
for the question you may inquire
is it my
my understanding is that you already we
already have laws that say that you
cannot stay in a room without proper id
i'm not aware of that i think that's
more of a business activity
would you believe i've already ran into
this issue we tried to rent a room for
uh
a relative in town they didn't have id
they would not rent the room even though
we were paying for it she had no id so
she could not get a room
so she drove home that night
i'm famous for those
okay
yeah i
obviously the only other question i have
is um
and when i read this definition of
lodging house
it somewhat implies that if i have two
or more rooms or habitually and i don't
know what habitual means but if i rent
out the my property enough
that means i have to uh
have signatures from these people who
booked online
and through a you know through airbnb
verbo
how i don't have any of that
well as i said uh
mr chair uh
open into language that would allow this
to go forward into the future for many
decades as this bill has
set in the back corner for many decades
would be appropriate now
banning it all outright i will disagree
with the constituent that brought this
forward uh for the reasons that he will
explain but
uh
opening the language i think
can replace uh
the first sentence uh very very
easily uh maintain a record
uh verify identity
that kind of uh
language
would allow
future
record keeping in whatever manner
happens to be the most efficient for the
business
as well as give law enforcement the
needed access to the information i do
think that if law enforcement's going to
go in and rummage through the records of
who's sleeping in which hotel or cavan
or whatever
uh
they probably should have a reason for
doing that rather than
not have a reason fair enough thank you
very much thank you
all right we'll call on richard khan who
the constituent who has a real life
good morning good morning
thank you ladies and gentlemen of this
committee
my name is richard khan i live in hudson
new hampshire
i'm going to cover three main points
number one
the civil liberties
issue number two
possible law enforcement point of view
and number three what makes it personal
for me
before representative allery agreed to
submit this bill on my behalf he says
i need you to talk to chief avery
bill avery is the chief of police in my
hometown of hudson new hampshire
the first thing chief avery said to me
was
i wasn't aware that there was this law
allowing law enforcement to see the
hotel registration log whether it's
cards or computers doesn't matter
on demand
okay
he says when he has to go i think hudson
has like two
hotels in it
and he says when he has to search a
business hotel or otherwise
his words not mine
that he likes to get a warrant because
and the prosecutors in court appreciate
that because it makes their case in
that's his words okay
he said also that he would check with
somebody i don't know who he spoke with
in the attorney general's office to see
what the compelling law enforcement
interest in it was and he has
he wasn't able to find out as far as i
can tell
okay
number two is the
civil liberties issue
police
should always need a warrant to search
any
business or
private property i heard it mentioned
that there's always well what if there's
something really bad that happened and
they have reason to believe the suspects
in this hotel well
exigent circumstances i heard that
already mentioned
now
the third point which is the one that
makes it personal to me
is where my family came from
especially on my dad's side now i know a
lot of people compare when they don't
like something and they want to make a
point that compared to the nazis
well my father was born and raised in
what became nazi germany
i used to ask him
and my late uncle walter when were you
first aware you had to leave the country
and i am going to tie this back to this
bill
for them the defining moment was 1936 my
dad was in some kind of children's camp
and he remember seeing signs around
germany uden unervunch meaning jews not
welcome
my uncle walter
when he
uh he remembers in july of 1936
riding in the back seat of the car with
my grandparents
somehow
my grandparents got word
that german soldiers had come to the
hotel they were staying at asking if
there were any jews staying there
grandma looks at grandpa says we need to
go
as in leave the country took about two
years to get their affairs in order to
make the transition to this country
so picture
somebody coming in
and if you don't think it can happen in
this country
well
maybe we there is a santa claus but
basically somebody coming to in a
uniform
wanting to see the hotel
registration log whether it's
paper or computer let's see
einstein
goldberg
khan
those sound like jewish names
well
by the way my father
still alive
uh he served in the u.s navy in world
war ii uh he's 95 years old so
unfortunately he could not be here to
confirm this but
he said that it wasn't german soldiers
that had come to the hotel it was the ss
in other words hitler's private army
okay
my interest in this bill
is wanting to make sure that
we are not going to
fall into that trap well
trusting the law enforcement to use the
proper restraint and getting the warrant
unless they really have exegen
circumstances
i'd like a little bit more reassurance
and with that i'm done i'll take any
questions
okay
thank you for a very compelling story
thank you for your time
uh the chair will call on michael
thornton
michael thornton
milford new hampshire speaking as an
individual
support hb
1378 will submit
because of the experiences of sergeant
first class clarence e thornton
who was wounded on 20 december 1944
and captured soon thereafter
during what became the battle of the
bulge
he was illegally leased
as a slave by the camp commandant
he was lucky
his new owners
were candy store owners an elderly
couple
under the protection of the camp
commandant
they insisted he drank a cup
of warm
liquid candy base each day
after all
a slave who can't work is worthless
thanks to their kindness
the sergeant saw the horrors of that war
the internment of his fellow soldiers
and of the adjacent
there were no geneva rights
accorded
he was finally liberated
26 march 1945
after the war ended
he was
assigned as an intelligence officer in
germany
he loved the german people with cause
he hated
the nazis
with cause
the cry of
papers
they said it happened
so
slowly and then it happened so fast
you want
to travel
papers you want lodging
papers
this is america
this must not happen here
we already have real id
we have mandates we have talk of vaccine
passports
papers
this is just a slight inconvenience
it's all for the common good
papers
one small step at a time
innkeeper
just such a slight inconvenience
please limit
this invasion of privacy
please require a search warrant issued
only under probable cause
sergeant thornton would thank you
please support
representative terry
yes sir thank you for your testimony uh
for all those um who would say or rather
no doubt will say
um this could never happen here
or um
this is different
how would you respond
it is happening here
representative thank you
every day
we see
additional laws
it is said currently
that an american citizen
doing their very best
cannot help
but infringe on an existing law already
we are already asked
for picture id
at the grocery store
everywhere we go
it is a creep
we do under article 3 surrender some of
our rights
not
what is it it's not defined not half
your rights not most of your rights some
we risk
for the question you may inquire
uh finally just to clarify
do you believe that what you're
observing
and and uh informed by your life
experience uh may very well be impinging
upon
our unalienable rights to life liberty
and the pursuit of happiness
it does not
currently
prohibit
it does
slow
if you've gone swimming
and you're walking back to your beach
house
and you're
asked by an officer could i see your id
please
it's difficult to produce
officers right over there in the room
will you come with me
if you walk out of the house without
your wallet
you don't see the sign and make a left
turn where it's prohibited and you don't
have
the science fiction author robert a
heinlein said
when you can't live your life without
we are not there
yet
representative mackel here
um thank you chairman what would your
opinion be
on a voter id
in order to vote
is that impinging
in that case if we look
at
the community's right
to have a fair
point of order please mr chairman i'm
wondering what um producing an id
a voter for to vote has to do with this
particular bill
uh
which has to do with a warrant for
probable cause
i just want to get you to clarify that
he
took liberties okay with his testimony
and so we're just
playing it out because he opened the
door
okay thank you certainly and i welcome
the question
a fair and honest election
in a republic a democracy quasi
democracy
is essential
the identification for that is minimal
it is free for the asking
you're supposed to have proof of
residence
that is your responsibility which you
accept freely as a citizen and if you
wish to vote
it is not
forced upon you
that
representatives as i feel the difference
uh
reverend herbert was next and then
represented bartlett
um i um do you believe
um
that
everybody knows they give a lot of
information away when they're on the
internet
that
category of information sharing would
fit in
in this discussion
it is similar
to a
published
book which is
circulating
after the copyright has expired
it is
in the open domain you have released
that information
voluntarily you've given it up
and you've done so under the internet
conditionally
you haven't you've got you have the
option to say
don't sell my information
don't publish who i am where i am and
what i purchased
that's the determination
well we have a bill that does that
tomorrow so come on bye
representative bartlett did you have a
question
thank you mr chair
um
so you're feeling that
we have to show id in many different
ways
and then you've also made
the statement that we live in a quasi
democracy would you please expound on
that
yes uh thank you representative bartlett
um
the
definition of a
true democracy i was reading on an
article i'm sorry i can't
remember specifically where but it
it listed america as a failed democracy
we are not a true
democracy we're a republic i'm sorry i'm
going to interrupt you if you can't
remember where it came from i feel like
that's hearsay
well
thank you
say it a different way
we
are not a pure democracy
under our founding documents we are
formed
as
we have
guaranteed
rights that originated
from our maker
that so-called natural rights we
voluntarily give up some
to participate in our community
we give up others
in a daily basis incidentally to do
commerce
when we vote
here
in new hampshire it is entirely
different from other places i lived ohio
massachusetts california if you did not
register 30 days prior and did not
produce id
you could not vote
period
we are
extremely
free and forgiving state
it would be wonderful
if we
great on that note thank you very much
uh so i have two cards left
mike summers from new hampshire lodging
and restaurant association takes no
position on the bill but like to speak
thank you mr chairman um close to the
mic
yes can you hear me sorry yeah uh money
for the record mike summers new
hampshire president ceo of new hampshire
lodging and restaurant association
uh we aren't really taking a bill a
position on the bill as written um
frankly we would leave it to you all as
our policy leaders makers uh to
determine
how this should play out
uh but since uh this bill opens the door
in this section of the statute we have
another concern which chairman hunt
actually alluded to earlier which is the
section that refers to shall keep a book
a card system calls each guest to sign
there in his own legal name or name by
which he is no commonly known said book
a card system etc uh frankly in today's
day and age hotel commerce you guys
already kind of discussed this uh with
you know the pandemic and contactless
payment contactless check-in uh in some
hotels in some states you don't even go
to the front desk or talk to anybody you
essentially get your checking in your
phone you run up to the door you tap the
door door pops open
so ultimately we'd like to see that kind
of removed
and to representative ulrie's testimony
earlier this section of the statute
hasn't been updated since 1973 so i
think it's time that we did something we
don't necessarily have a clear
recommendation of what that should be
but we're certainly happy to work with
the committee to figure out what that
one of the questions that was asked or
statements made earlier about having an
id to rent that is more of a business
decision than required by statute in the
state of new hampshire but that business
it stems from the fact that you don't
necessarily want to be
tricked into allowing somebody to rent
who's using false identification
or no identification false credit cards
those so identity theft and those kinds
of scenarios so i don't believe anywhere
in statutes required in new hampshire
but most businesses do require it as a
as a protection of the business
and since we're here and going through
all the old statutes i thought i'd throw
a couple other options on the table for
you
also within section 353
section 3a posting of rental rates
requires that you have your minimum of
maximum room rates posted inside the
hotel room that was last updated in 1979
and frankly i think most hotels in the
state are in violation of that part of
the statute as well simply because the
rates change almost daily at this point
it's all online we've all seen it so it
becomes kind of a moot point
the other section i would throw out
there is 353.5 which is under signs
hasn't been updated since 1959
which also requires that if you are
going to post the room rate outside on
the side of the road you have to have
your minimum and maximum prices and it
has to be of a size that can be read by
the traveling public uh so
again if you're going to open the can of
worms we're going to go all in on this
so
i thought i would
i would offer those to the committee for
consideration uh i'm certainly happy to
try to answer any questions you may have
but um it's here we figured we would ask
so is there anything in the actual rsa
353 that you would think we should keep
or should we just repeal the whole thing
i think there are some sections we
should keep yes
um
i could read the list if you like but uh
we'll we'll look at it save that for
another day yes
okay representative below
thank you mr chair thank you for taking
my question
um you represent the restaurant lodging
association were there a little closer
to mike with their specific um hotels or
um
bed and breakfast owners that
phoned
you
yeah
in regards to this bill yes thank you
for the question representative so yes i
have been contacted by a few members and
again this is kind of a side effect of
the pandemic frankly
but we do have some facilities that are
either have switched over to are in the
process of switching over to that
contactless check-in payment system so
they found themselves in a bit of a
conundrum about well if they don't
actually come to the front desk and talk
to anybody how do i get them to sign
something because we're of adopted
technologies in order to deliberately
avoid that that transaction head
scenario so i did get a few property
owners that had called me and asked
questions about that unfortunately when
we had these conversations in the fall
we'd already missed filing deadlines so
we didn't really take it up but when we
found this bill had been conveniently
filed we thought we would jump in on the
coattails so to speak
thank you mr chairman thank you sir for
taking our questions uh aside a little
closer to the mic
so aside from all of the uh out of date
language of the overall section
the
this bill specifically has
bolded
that
law enforcement would require a warrant
in which probable cause has been
attested
lodging owners lodging keepers whatever
you want to call them
that this law would pertain to
in having some record of who is on the
property
and then upon presentation of a warrant
providing that information to law
enforcement
because that's that's the crux of the
bill regardless of all the other changes
that might need to be made this bill
specifically deals with providing a
warrant
for law enforcement or excuse me law
enforcement requiring a warrant
um thank you representative and as i
said at my opening statement we don't
haven't really taken a position on
requiring a warrant we obviously will
work with law enforcement we value their
partnership uh we certainly have seen um
and i think you're going to hear in
follow-up testimony we've certainly seen
that there has been human trafficking
and other kinds of issues that have
started to develop into new hampshire a
little bit so we certainly have some
concerns about you know law enforcement
enforcement's ability to react to that
again we leave that to you all as our
esteemed policy makers to figure out
what that should look like and what that
balance should be
but going back to the keeping of the
record
i i most businesses would keep it anyway
but i do think that there should be some
record kept by the business for obvious
reasons right um so that in the event
that enforcement has to do some sort of
investigation three months later that
there is some record that needs to be
that can be reviewed to track people's
uh progress uh in the event that they're
you know chasing a felon or whatever it
might be
but beyond that um you know most
businesses would keep the record simply
because they're not going to need
records of these transactions simply for
irs purposes and other areas that they
they're
required to report or maintain but um
but beyond that we're not really
adopting a position on the law
enforcement aspect of it we obviously
representative terry
on a lighter note i trust as we draw to
the conclusion of
the q a on your testimony thank you for
your testimony and with respect to the
broader concerns that you've raised with
respect to section 353 i would just like
to thank you for enlightening me as to
the possible reason why and i believe
this is not only the case in new
hampshire but other states
a number of years ago
i have a firm recollection of
taking a motel room for the night
for a rather reasonable rate of 79 or 99
but when i looked at the back of the
door inside of the back of the door it
indicated that the maximum room rate was
over a thousand dollars
uh thank you very much i think i've got
it now
will be called the wreck rate
well and if i can respond i think that's
really the problem right you you
post that on the back of a door and
frankly you have to put in you know it
might be 99 and it could be 2500 a night
depending on what's going on so and
hotels end up putting these wildly
astronomical numbers because they don't
want to get caught in this thing where
well you know that's higher or lower
than the posted rate et cetera so
um
the one other thing i was going to add
was
the
discussion around id um you know really
a big part of the requirement of the
idea is a credit card right so you use
your credit card to
reserve the room but then you're coming
in you're actually going to pay with a
credit card you're wanting the id to
back up the fact that you are actually
the person that has rights to use that
credit card so anyway i defer thank you
uh representative vargas
yes
thank you um for your testimony you have
to pull close to mike close
oh can you hear me now yes okay thank
you thank you for your testimony i'm
curious are there any protocols today
that you're aware of in in the
association um that if a police officer
or any law enforcement agent comes in
and asks for this information
what what what's the protocol today is
this just information that gets released
i know i can't even find out you know
like if my husband's upstairs so i'm
just a little curious about that so
currently again under the current
statute if uh an officer comes in and
requests it we're gonna uh share with
them information we
most of our businesses would do it in a
limited fashion and usually it would be
a case of and i would defer to obviously
the sheriff's etc but usually they would
come in and ask about a specific
individual they're not coming in to just
see the entirety of who's in the hotel
um but usually that information is
shared because i think most hoteliers in
the state understand that they're
required to share that information with
law enforcement
thank you
all right thank you very much thank you
okay brian
nukem we saved the best for last here
for us to tell us why
why you really are in opposition to this
bill
well i'm not going to fit in the chair
so
thank you representative hunt my name is
brian newcombe newcomb
i'm employed by the hillsborough county
sheriff's office and uh for the past 19
and a half years
i'm here on behalf of the hillsborough
county sheriff christopher conley and
the new hampshire association of chiefs
of police
i'm here to testify in opposition of
house bill 1378 relative to the
inspection of public lodging houses
hotels tourist camps and other public
lodging provide people with a temporary
place to stay most people utilize them
for reasons such as visiting local
attractions business trips visiting
family friends or other leisure
activities
most reasons uh people use hotels
for
pleasant activities
hotels however
have people that visit for
more menacing reasons hotels provide an
attractive place for drug dealing drug
using prostitution human trafficking
sexual exploitation of children white
collar crimes fugitives because the
hotels offer a place of anonymity
i'd like to talk a little bit about
the process
in which we inspect the
hotel logs
a lot of times we're dealing with
criminals who have arrest warrants who
are on the run from crimes that could
range from the most petty to the most
serious
when we are investigating someone that's
wanted for a crime we may go talk to
somebody and they may say hey joe is
staying over at a hotel in manchester
so we would go to a hotel in manchester
and we would request to see
you know the guest log book to see if
his name is on it however when you don't
have the specific hotel that they're
staying at
it's very hard to get a warrant
to follow up with that case
therefore we're going to all the hotels
in manchester or merrimack or nashua or
whatever it may be so it's a very fluid
the current
trend right now is
people
will
rent hotel rooms either under their name
or under a friend's name
and they will set up shop to sell drugs
or do other illegal activity
hotels are a busy place so the uptick in
traffic really isn't suspicious most
times
and they do that because it's not as
suspicious as if they were doing it at
their own house where the neighbors
would call or other residents down the
street would call if something was out
of place
often these activities are happening
in a room right next to a family that's
trying to enjoy a vacation or a business
traveler
one example that
that kind of comes to light that just
a few people got arrested in milford new
hampshire for possession of
methamphetamine
the investigators over there
found out that someone that we the
hillsborough county sheriff's office had
a warrant for was their supplier and
they were staying at the at a hotel in
manchester
they provided us with the hotel which
was great
we
investigators went over to the hotel we
spoke with the
innkeeper who was very pleasant
and we provided them with the name that
we were looking for that name was not on
the list she showed us the whole list
and we were able to identify an
associate of his from the list and we
were able to ultimately go up knock on
the door arrest them take them into
custody and we end up finding a large
amount of methamphetamine and some other
illegal items right that's another a
positive
kind of getting down the the
the sexual exploitation exploitation
aspect of it
um
we work very closely with the internet
crimes against children task force we
have a an officer assigned to it
we do a lot of cases with them
and
over the past year there have been
several cases where an adult has
made arrangements to meet up with a
minor in a hotel room now when these
cases come in they're very very fluid
they're very quickly
developing
so we were able to identify the hotel
that they had planned to meet this miner
at
and
we were able to go in
ask if their name was there they showed
us the guest log book we confirmed that
this person was actually serious about
following through with his act
ultimately that person got arrested at
the hotel but it's just another rung in
confirming that this person is really
serious about what's happening
human trafficking as was spoken about
before
is
predominantly a major problem at local
hotels and when i say in hillsborough
county we deal with nashua merrimack
bedford and manchester merrimack i don't
know if any of you are from that area
had a tremendous problem with um the
drug and prostitution um it started
about two years ago when the there's a
correct people wrong i think there's
four hotels that are there and they were
basically dropping their rates to see
who could get the most people on there
and sell out which is fine but it
attracts a different clientele when that
happens so
we were able to uncover human
trafficking cases going on there and
that was simply by going in there and
looking at the list and saying hey
a name popped out to us that we know is
a sex worker
it's not uncommon for us
as law enforcement to go knock on that
person's door and say hey are you okay
they may be in there doing nothing right
now but
sometimes we've offered services and
they've taken us up on those services to
get them out of that situation they're
not there willingly but they are there
because they either have an addiction
problem or they're they're they're
it's they're forced to be there for some
other reason for money or whoever has
control over them
but for them to know that we're around
checking on them offering them services
it's the best that we can and you know
there have been people that we have
gotten you know out of that lifestyle
i'm not saying all of them i'm saying we
do our best to do that that's a success
in in my book and by simply looking at a
list
to see who's on there to prevent crime
is is very important and i want to take
the opportunity to talk about what the
next step is in that so if we we
identify that illegal activity is going
on in joe's room
um we're going to get a search warrant
to do that we're not going to nilly
willy go in there we're not going to
blow down the door and do that we're
going to get our ducks in a row but that
list is certainly a
it's the first level in establishing
your probable cause that crime is going
on or that there could be something
illegal going on or or whatever we are
going to put this in front of a judge
after that
to to go to the next step
and i don't know if anyone here has ever
applied for a search warrant or dealt
with that it's a very cumbersome process
it takes
hours to write
even on the smallest case and then we do
have a new electronic system that's uh
supposedly more efficient but
typically the more emerging situations
are put to the the top of the list to
get signed by a judge so on a basic
search warrant for a hotel guest blog
book
that would assume that we would get it
back between 8 and 48 hours depending on
when the when the judge would would sign
that okay and that's no fault of them
it's just it's a busy nature and that's
that's what
happens um there are many sophisticated
organizations that operate up and down
the east coast i'm sure you you have
read about in the paper watching the
news they travel up here they go to your
local gyms they steal your wallets they
go to you and then they take your wallet
and your checks and they go
cash them at the banks
that is a huge part of this white collar
industry that's staying at these hotels
and we've had great success when
patrolmen are on the street and they're
going they're checking the hotels
because hey we're getting hit with these
forgeries and thefts they check the
hotels they see a name on the list
that's associated with one of these
organizations and they're able to either
set up surveillance make an arrest if
that person has a warrant or
prevent future crime from happening
um i'll bring it up and this is kind of
a public safety issue is there was a
recent double homicide in bedford new
hampshire
less than a year ago eight months ago i
was there
those guest log
logs were absolutely crucial in
identifying
the victims in that case they were
crucial in identifying people that were
not involved in that case and making
sure people were accounted for
that was a tremendous help in getting
those people out of that hotel safely
and effectively and making sure that we
weren't
dealing with
looking for someone else that was
potentially injured or harmed and that
was a very sensitive crime scene and i
can tell you we were there for days
and
that is one of the best stories that
that i can portray about the the use of
those those log books
um
and also
the police shooting that happened in
manchester about a year and a half ago
at the hotel there
that was crucial in getting people out
of the out of the hotels to get them out
of the way but also who we were dealing
with when you're looking at the logs and
you're saying you know joe um
joe rented the room
but we know that joe has the following
friends and there's four people in there
we think that these people are are
potentially there so it gives us an
advantage on knowing who who's who's in
there when we're dealing with the
criminal element and law enforcement
aren't we're not just going to the
hotels to
just say hey who's in the room who's
here who's there who's staying here
we all operate with policies and
procedures in a professional way and
transparency these days is very
important to everybody and it's
important to citizens it's important to
us
when we
interact with the innkeepers that are
dealing with uh with people at their
hotel it's a very positive experience
and a lot of times it's having a cup of
coffee with them and they're talking
about hey these are the problems we're
seeing we see this guy coming in here
every every week or you know a lot of
people lording outside you know we may
make a recommendation hey maybe you
should put some some more lighting
outside a couple have a couple places
have done that
but it's a very positive experience
between
the
innkeepers and ourself
the current laws are written allows for
law enforcement to inspect a book
or guest book without a warrant this is
a very
effective investigative tool that is
often used to combat illegal activity if
the laws change and law enforcement is
required to get a search warrant to
review guest logs this will be a major
hindrance in combating illegal activity
allowing criminals even more anonymity
public safety would suffer if law
enforcement needed a search warrant for
representative bartlett has a question
thank you mr chair thanks for coming um
forward and talking to us about real
live
instances of when it's necessary for law
enforcement to access these log books
um
would it be your your testimony that
most innkeepers
want your help to get people
that are breaking the law out of their
establishment absolutely that's their
goal and that's our goal they don't want
to have someone that's going to be a
problem in their hotel that could be
affecting other guests or committing
crimes while they're there maybe
damaging the the rooms themselves so
they are very positive in that in that
manner
for the question you mean
thank you um so
it would it would be your testimony that
this is something regarding public
safety we you're not looking
as has been heard this morning about a
quasi democracy that
law enforcement is
stepping on individual rights of our
citizens that's correct are our officers
investigators and i can speak for
investigators throughout the state and
especially hillsborough county is
caseloads are so high right now um that
nobody really has time to just go out
and check hotel lists on a whim to be
like hey we're going to check hotel
lists and see what's what's going on
here today it's more of a targeted
a targeted issue you're there because
you have a a case a reason
and you're following the procedures and
i don't want people to think that we are
going to the hotel hotel looking at
their log and then we're going to kick
their door and that's that's 100 percent
false
we follow the same
rules and regulations as it would be to
get a search warrant to establish
probable cause to further that case
we're not about
violating anyone violating anyone's
rights there because i wouldn't want my
representative terry
thank you thank you for your testimony
um
i just want to essentially ask you the
same question that i asked the previous
uh individual who testified part of it
and and i want to understand
that um and have you have you confirmed
what i think i'm hearing and and that is
that in response to the question um
things are different
here
different now they're not like those
situations that happened in
germany in the 1930s and 40s
in the soviet union under joseph stalin
in china under mao
and questionably in some other countries
perhaps even today
that there's something about what the
moral fabric
and culture of the united states that
this need not be a concern now
is is is that is that partly what i'm
hearing could you speak to that please
um sure
i think um
i should have paid attention a lot more
in school uh when you when you brought
up those names and stuff
my wife is a teacher and should be
ashamed um
but i uh
i do understand where you're going with
the question
and i think that we live in a world
right now where police transparency is
on the forefront of what's happening and
i think that every department in the
state has
put
in place
safeguards
to
accomplish certain measures and means
for an operation get approved i have to
send it to my boss and he approves it um
i think that
it is different now because
crime is so rapidly revolving and it's
getting so technical where you could
like the gentleman before me said you
could sign into your hotel room with
just your phone and then you can pop
over to maybe rent another room in
another hotel with your phone so you're
double insulating yourself with a sense
rep representative
thank you mr chair thank you for coming
and testifying for us uh you mentioned
transparency uh
would an alternative to this bill uh
would you accept an alternative to this
bill
that would require
the police to notify the public
when they ask for
the records of a of a hotel some kind of
disclosure maybe on the department's
website that they asked the date officer
and so forth
so i think if i understand your your
question um that would be a uh more of a
regulatory um protocol
as uh maybe on a quarterly basis or is
that like a daily basis i'm not sure
what you're where you're how
fluid
you mentioned transparency and that was
uh you know very important these days
it would be transparent of the
department if they would notify the
public when they went to a hotel
and asked to see the records you know
the the
we would have some transparency in that
request
um i would have to speak with uh some of
the other
chiefs of police on that so that we
could have a better um understanding of
where we're all at collectively but a
police log would show that we we were
there
thank you for uh answering our questions
lieutenant um
i guess i really have more than one
question in
in all of this but you you use in your
testimony that the there's an element of
people that utilize hotels for darker
and more menacing reasons
uh that can be said about just about
everything
uh
people
criminals are criminals they're bad guys
it doesn't matter where they commit
their crimes or where they try to hide
out and so does the fact that crimes may
occur at a hotel supersede due process
of law rules of evidence and civil
rights and with that we've been
conflating laws or excuse me crimes in
progress versus looking for a suspect in
a criminal activity that has occurred in
the past and so no one wants no one
wants the bad guys to get away with
their with their crimes we all want the
bad guys off the streets and your job is
to get them off the streets but we also
have a judicial system in this country
rights
even the criminal has the right of due
process of law right that's correct so
that that requires certain actions on
your part
you want to make sure the bad guy goes
to jail so that the evidence that you
collect is within the rules of evidence
and you've you've dotted all the eyes
and crossed all the t's right you want
to put them away you don't want to get
out on technicality
so
does the fact that these crimes occur at
hotels supersede due process of law and
the fact that you need to get a warrant
and does and does a warrant requiring a
warrant
interfere or prevent the innkeeper from
volunteering information
so that's gonna be a multiple part
answer to your question so
everyone here has constitutional rights
and no one wants to get them violated
because we want these cases to go forth
without a hiccup we don't want anything
thrown out on a technicality as you say
when a hotel room or house is searched
whether someone could give consent to
search a hotel room they could give
consent to search their residence that's
not a big deal however
if we apply for a search warrant we
established probable cause we
established that it's been reviewed by a
neutral and detached magistrate or judge
and that has been put forth signed
either either signed or not signed they
may say we don't have it sometimes but
it's signed that gives us the
authorization to go ahead and search
your room i think what we're talking
here is simply looking at a
list
of people that are staying in a hotel
room that are paying a room and board
tax to stay there i think that that is
no different than me looking up your
address
online on a vision appraisal or the tax
assessor's
website
thank you
so um
you you talked about a a
policeman walking down the street and
just walking into the hotel and looking
at the registry did i misunderstand you
that you said that has happened
just randomly looked at a registry um
i'm sure it has happened but typically
they're there for for some for some
reason i can talk about the the
sophisticated white collar crew that
comes up um typically it starts with um
you may have a bulk theft at
lowe's in bedford and you know it's out
of state plates and you may go over to
the hotel to see if that car is matching
it you may go into there to see if um
someone's staying in there that matches
a previous um so how often or do you
have you heard any anecdotal stories
where one where a hotel said no
no
so really this law even though it exists
has never been used
maybe
well the law is used every time we go in
there no i'm not saying the law is not
used because you're not
enforcing you're not saying due to this
rsa 355 333 you need to show me
your registry
you're just saying is you don't have a
problem going into any hotel
and having them show you the registry
well i can tell you that about 18 years
ago i did have an issue at a hotel where
someone was like oh i don't know if i
can give you those and i cited the this
law that we're talking about today
and they didn't had no idea about it so
they were educated on that on that law
but i think that all the innkeepers and
the corporate chains
have informed and trained their
employees on the rights that are
respected to each state that they're
operating in so well
and that gets me what really scares me
about this bill is that most of us don't
even know it exists
and my fear is that
because we don't have a book or card
system
i guess you're looking when you say the
registry at this point you're looking to
say is do you have a list of all your
people who are in the hotel tonight
and
i don't
i have a vacation rental
i'm lucky to have just the person who
booked it
i don't know anybody else is in the
place
so am i in violation of this statute
if you're if you're renting it out for
more than uh
more than the the two days a consistent
basis two rooms in less than a week yeah
yeah yeah and vacation rental yeah you
know you've heard about the vacation
rentals right in the state here that's
kind of a controversy
yeah
so so we're all in violation but uh but
i'm just saying is that so what is a
hotel does a hotel literally turn the
computer around and let you look screen
through the list but what are you
getting from a hotel
typically what we get is a redacted
version we get they'll print it out and
they usually eliminate all the credit
card information and all that other
stuff and you get a list of of names and
however format that they're putting them
out or sometimes they'll just let you
that does seem a little scary about
privacy issues but um
having the idea that
law enforcement can uh
to do this you've never had except this
one case where a person said i didn't
know this law existed but in every other
case most people said yeah i have no
problems showing you or trying to help
you and give you all the information you
need is that correct that's correct okay
so we we have to figure out how do we
make it so that the person who doesn't
how do we
protect them from not
violating the law and having you say oh
by the way you just violated the statute
you don't have a list
that's going to be a
task for this committee to to research i
think that there is a lot of work ahead
on the vacation end of it with the the
airbnbs and the and the the rental if
you have a house at the lake that you're
renting on a pretty regular basis on you
know during certain months but you're
not renting on other months i think that
maybe that should be subdivided out from
this into into something else because i
think that that what you're talking
about is it's a very it's a very real
issue that's going on because of of the
you know where technology is with
airbnbs and rentals i think that that's
something that maybe should be
segregated out because it's not as
complex well i'm just saying but you
only have one name
you have the person who booked the room
there could be four or five people in
that room
then we would have to do our due
diligence to to find out if there was a
crime committed or if that's even what
we're looking for
at that end we simply would have the one
room the one name that's on it but
that's where that first investigative
step takes place that we would have to
further our investigation from there
okay
if needed if needed representative
herbert
if we passed the law for example that
said that uh you under you cannot ask
actually ask for a list
or somebody says well i don't have the
list anyway because i don't have to have
one
uh would that hinder
your ability to enforce the law that
would significantly hinder it
thank you
representative
so as i understand um you could ask for
the list and you would see all the names
as well as the name that you'd be
which leads to my question
i i guess i i never realized that i do
not have an expectation
of privacy when i register at a hotel or
a motel
that it's a transaction between me and
the motel and the hotel owner
because hypothetically law enforcement
could come in
and ask to see a list upon which my name
would appear whether i'm the person of
interest or not
under current law and this is to
chairman hunt's point about you know do
people even know that this exists i
guess i'm i i'm asking you to confirm
that that i do that the same expectation
of privacy and constitutional rights
that are extended to me
under whatever amendment it is i can't
remember the about the
right to
search and seizure
without a warrant in the constitution
in the section we know is the bill of
rights
that that
when i when i'm temporarily residing in
a
place of public lodging that expectation
of privacy it does not exist any longer
under current law in new hampshire
correct
thank you very much thank you
uh having no more cards
we had um overnight we had eight people
in support one opposed
and
for who testified today
uh michael thornton is for it pamela
kelling is
against it
justin rowe is
sherry khan is for it and elizabeth
starting for the new hampshire
association of chiefs of police is
against it and with that we will close
this is lund before long this is lunch
we're not coming back until 1 15. so
that's one hour for lunch that's perfect
we were saying about the fbi they're
going around all the hotels in dc
getting the names of people they know
are the poor boys and all that
they went through the list
so these fire these guys are saying no
is
okay
yes
uh
says
hello
oh
all right come on up and uh
explain this one to us because
good afternoon honorable members of the
committee thank you for the opportunity
for this chance to speak
for the record my name is cheryl air i
am the director
of weights and measures which is under
the department of agriculture markets
and food
i am here to speak in support of house
bill 1249
this is a housekeeping item that gives
clarity to two scale categories and
includes two definitions that give
additional clarity to the proposed
changes
the term analytical balance in our
current statute is vague as to what
category of scale is referenced
since analytical is a term most often
used in a laboratory setting
the scale categories in rsa 438 10a are
used to determine how commercially used
devices are licensed with our division
this housekeeping item will clear up any
ambiguity by changing the term
analytical to precision
defining precision and adding additional
language to the 100 pounds or less
category to include the words other than
precision scales so each scale category
are there any questions
it's it's really simple it's
straightforward okay so you want to tell
us what kind of scales we're talking
about just give us an idea
what ball park are we in here for the
precision category we're talking about
any of the scales that are used in
buying or selling
precious metals
sometimes people use those same scales
to sell herbs
expensive teas
so that's that's the kind of scale that
we're talking about
so what happened was in
in the statute can you get a little
closer to my sure
thank you
one of the categories um
says
a hundred pounds or less for that
category
so
that could be
assumed that that included any of our
gram or metric scales
we have special equipment that we use to
to audit those precision scales
and
the analytical balance term does not
properly reflect those scales because
analytical
and analytical balance is more often
used in a laboratory setting
but these are scales that are actually
okay oh my gosh all right
we'll start here and we'll go all the
way around representative terry you're
up thank you so as i i begin to try to
understand what's going on here and
thank you for your
explanation which helps me along the way
uh
is there a reason
why you would retain
in line three 100 pounds rather than to
utilize the more commonly used metric
grams or kilograms
given that it's 2022 and not
1852 any longer
is there is there a rationale for
continuing that not changing that
that's an interesting point because in
our in our law it does re um allow for
metrics to be utilized when we were
looking at defining the term precision
that's why we did in that category
define it with both metric and ava
dupois
reference
we i
i just did not change the the
would you consider that in in the future
given that it's it's quite prevalent and
common in this day and age to use metric
measurements which are more precise
absolutely okay thank you
representative johnson
thank you for taking my question
excuse me
so i'm just so i understand this bill
because this is all new to me
would this when you when you're talking
precision scales are you talking you
know i've worked in you know the
industry
where
some of the
um
grocery stores and
small supermarkets will use a scale to
measure their meats to sell
are you talking these type of precision
scales also no that would be in the
hundred pounds or less category
okay
thank you you're welcome
okay you guys you're all sad all right
this is just to satisfy my curiosity
thank you for taking my questions uh
could you tell us about how these
scales and different
instruments are
calibrated and maintained over time okay
so um
we're required to have any commercial
device that is used
commercially
certified state certified
every single year
now
we do this in order to protect the
consumer and their interests we want to
make sure that those devices are
operating in a proper manner
and so
[Music]
by licensing them in the correct
category we know what type of equipment
to utilize to go out and test these
devices
now in
if any of you are aware of the national
institute of standards and technology
down in gaithersburg maryland
they are the ones that put together our
handbooks for the national conference on
weights and measures
in the
nist handbook 112
which is an online version now
they actually specify what the
examination procedure outlines are
when a device is certified
and so we require
service companies that are also licensed
with our office to follow the
examination procedure
in order to
discern whether those devices are within
tolerance and whether they can be state
certified
did i answer
your question
for the question
yeah and then to take that back a step
further the
companies that you the vendors that you
contract with how do they make sure that
their instruments are calibrated good
question so
um
we also require any of those service
technicians that are licensed with a
division of weights and measures to have
their equipment calibrated
on an annual basis so every year they
have to have their equipment calibrated
and they
they report that information to us so
that we can track it to make sure that
the equipment they are using
is appropriate for the devices that
they're certifying
so is that a third party or do they have
that that system in-house it is
we are working to get some of the
ability to be in-house we have a state
metrology lab that is currently working
very diligently to get accreditation
so that we can do some of the the
calibrating of that equipment ourselves
okay
representative thank you mr chairman
thank you for your testimony would you
believe once upon a time ago in another
lifetime i used to run a pmel lab
precision
measurement and we had to have our
standards
checked by the state and national
and when we went out
we had our certifications with us in the
book so that we could show the people
who had contracted us
that their weights or whatever are going
to be
uh okay
also would you believe once upon a time
in another lifetime
i worked in a precision
uh chemical laboratory
where the balance
the precision balance which was in the
glass
uh and we had to pick up the weights
with a pair of tweezers
we could not contaminate them with our
fingers
so i know both ends the gross and the
minute and
thank you for your testimony it was it's
nice seeing somebody from like my old
days thank you wonderful thank you
okay we're all set
thank you very much thank you
just so you all know this was um we were
supposed to be exec
today
this was remember the exec we did yes
last week
that this i had originally scheduled
this was we were going to get all our
bills out which
which are already done and they're
already on the way so
yeah
they did right so
okay
uh
and so we have uh
daniel richardson uh is in uh support of
the bill
and of course cheryl sort of bill
and with that we will close the public
hearing
thank you very much
so uh just so you know we we
we don't execute anything in the same
day we're we're not the senate you know
right but uh we we uh we will schedule a
subcommittee wheel because this is
technically under our business category
so you will see in the calendar that we
have a subcommittee on it and then we'll
execute the bill but
and and but we we we just go through the
subcommittee process just so we can make
sure we know who's going to carry
forward with the bill and write the
blurb but you gave us all kinds of good
things to write now on for ourselves so
thank you very much
okay
yes
let's see if i checked my name on the
list
where we have no privacy evidently any
okay so
no i haven't really thought about that i
mean to me executing is when we we got
you know done the subcommittees and we
got all our ducks in a row and know
where we're going with it
so next week we're doing nothing so the
following week we'll we'll schedule you
know um subcommittees
and then i might
yeah
i don't have to see how it fits how it
all fits in i get i got to take my
calendar out and figure that out
i have not done that i mean other than
the fact that yes you know come march
i'm going to the caribbean
and that's going to be uh
was it march 9th to the
to
uh i don't know ten it's nine days ten
days
so i i might miss a session day so i
don't know how that's gonna work out but
so
so that would be yeah so no yeah my
flight is at the end of the week so
we'll we'll meet that week
a couple of days there march 7. when
they may pull my calendar
so
right the night is uh
tonight is a wednesday huh
that's what i thought it was the 11th i
session days are going to be in there
because you know theoretically we have
to have everything done by the end of
so feel feel free to
you know not be here that way we can
match up you know we can
cross each other's boats
what they call pairing pairing
tuesday the first
that's a tuesday so no we have to be the
second
it's hoping that they've got it done by
that you know in terms of getting you
know
yeah so again it would be you know
we could possibly be exactly on the
right
so i can say that the one of our liquor
bills
the one that about the multiple computer
systems
the multiple point of sale systems
um so with that one um the liquor
commission is working on a bulletin
right now
to let all
uh licensees to know that yes they can
have just one computer so that's being
done the um the food cart thing
um
well there was the two of them it's the
food truck and then the the food cart
the food cart uh
food cart issue
what i would um i
suggested to the department is for we'll
have a uh
a you know
nanoplus so we'll have a food cart plus
and a food cart plus
will basically
take the concept of the what do you call
it a
commissary
and but that the key element i told him
is i want the commissary making sure
that the commissary could be somebody's
own kitchen or someone in their home
so that they could
take this you know zooped up
unit this you know the actual unit that
they're using for selling
that is going to be theoretically going
to have whatever you know proper heating
systems proper whatever
they could actually
take it to where they're going
on a trailer like a you know a lawnmower
trailer they could put it on the trailer
and then they could take it home
and clean it out
and i said and then have then have the
you know kind of the chili so you can
get a chili dog you can get whatever
that would be the full-fledged thing and
i said i understand you guys want to
make requirements about that you can't
reuse the chili then once you put the
chili in
the box you can't use it the next day
you know you had you got to make sure
that everything is is new and fresh i
said you you know basically i told them
um
and they they they feel very confident
and that if anything we'll just have a
statute then whether we need a statute
even to say that they'll have this
second level
yep
i thought the third bill that was
presented
that day
by representative aaron
would be the one that
we could vote on because it's a study
committee to study all the rules and
regulations on you know food carts and
food trucks and i thought that would
that would be the best way to go but you
know if you spoke if you
because
you were just talking about you know
making chili at home i mean you can't
make chili at home if you're in
manchester
and sell it on a food cart
you can't do that because that
manchester has a health
inspector
and they don't allow homesteading or
manufacturing
uh in cities in homes
uh there's part of me that hope that i
hear you and that oh well
so um but you know the part of me is
is that i would hope that
if we were to get get this accomplished
that some of these cities would then
rethink their policies and reflect the
state one
but that would be a state problem i
can't we can't and that really goes back
to this truck problem
i just don't think we can fix the truck
problem
um because at the end of the day that
you the the towns want to license and
regulate the truck themselves those
cities excuse me cities that want to do
it we can't stop them from doing that
and the idea that we should have a state
license that supersedes that license i
just
i i'm not ready to go there i don't know
how many people think that's a good idea
but
i just don't think we can do that
so but that if it is true that some
cities refuse to let people
have their home commissaries if they
that's their city's choice then that's
their city's choice and
and all you can do is urge and once we
have estate plan in place to urge them
to reconsider their
draconian position well and i imagine
anybody that owns a food truck or a cart
goes through the safe serve program
i mean that's necessary i would assume
that didn't you say that that the
manchester was requiring you to have the
state permit anyways
uh yes
right so so so it seems to me that yes
manchester's over-regulated if the
require you had a state permit and then
get a local permit
boy that seems a little
it's because they have a health
department
and that's in there
you know i'm just because they have a
health department right
there wasn't anybody from cities here i
know the
municipal um uh what's the not what's
the missible association yeah they were
here and then they left before
testifying because they were against the
bills
yeah yeah
but like i say i i'm not sure we can fix
that problem because you you're at the
end of the day those cities you know any
city's going to want to reserve the
right
to regulate and and zone frankly
where they yeah zoning's a whole other
issue right i mean and and frankly i
think the biggest barrier to that market
is what keith said
it's where you're going to you've got to
find a land you've got to find someone
who's going to take it and let you park
there yep
yeah it's a zoning issue it's a you know
it's more well i mean zoning it's it's a
look you know getting that initial
contract and you can drive your truck
all around but
you know unless you sit at a you know i
know i don't know do we lot our state
parks do we allow them to be in the
don't you think it would make sense
yeah it does that does make sense yeah
salmon yeah well if the truck had water
but you would mention that they were
going to try to do it in rules for this
hot dog new yeah
is it going to be in a another is it
going to be a
more expensive fee the fee would have to
reflect that there would be more
licensure regulation that they would
have to come and check out the kitchen
so it won't be a big fee difference but
because they got it they got to
rationalize sending someone out to look
at it so
no i just i just actually the idea that
uh that we were talking about was
wouldn't it be great that someone could
bring their
truck bring it to them
and and so that was something that they
they seemed that it's not a bad idea
they're you know to obviously to
facilitate that for customers yeah that
was my idea why couldn't they just do
like you know
a couple times a year or whatever where
they say all the food trucks need to
come in and get inspected right here's
your time slot everybody goes in it's
less it's it's more cost efficient to
have the truck i mean the trucks are
trucks
you know bring it to them they just do a
massive
day of inspections
right they can have water hook up there
so they and plug in so that everything's
done right there now they know that
certified and it's
in a controlled environment and saves
everybody time from running all over the
state
yeah
so
you